les vendanches ont commencé déjà depuis
quelques temps en Touren notamment dans
les vignobles d'Appellation d'Origine
d'appellation contrôlée à Montlouis à
vous vrai les vendanges battent leur
plein cependant on attend tout de même
encore quelques temps pour les tris
supérieurs aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
les vignobles les plus importants de
vouvra 50 hear madame F nous vous
remerons de nous accueillir chez vous le
raisin est bon je pense vous voulez le
goûter j'aimerais bien euh quant à la
qualité et à la quantité pourrions-nous
demander à votre oui ça c'est mon
technicien Monf de culture monsieur dark
qui va beaucoup mieux que Mo monsieur
dark la quantité euh la quantité cette
année est très faible quand à la qualité
ah la qualité est très bonne vous avez
déjà pesé quelques mou euh oui on trouve
des 12 et demi 13 faciles et vous n'êtes
pas en plein rendement actuellement vous
n'êtes pas encore au trit supérieur non
non non on n'est pas au TR supérieur
encore au point de vue vendangeur
qu'avez-vous comme vendangeurs des des
Français des étrangers des Portugais en
principe c'est que des saisonniers alors
que j'ai depuis 3 ans ce sont des
habitués oui des habitués de la maison
ils viennent ils reviennent ceci pour la
trè année de quel âge à quel âge de 16 à
40 45
c'est donc pas de problème de ce côtél
les hauteurs les cueilleurs tout va bien
tout va bien ils attendent avec une très
grande impatience le Berlot ah oui tout
le monde qu'est-ce que c'est que le
Berlot fait madame F ah B ça le Berlot
c'est une fête tradition et un tout
petit peu folcllorique c'est la fin de
la vendange alors on pend un espèce de
mannequin en P un arbre on enterre en
quelque sorte la vendange 69 on attend
laavendange 70 nous l'attendons tous
n'est-ce pas monsieur je pense qu'elle
sera enfin nous espérons qu'elle sera
très bonne n'est-ce pas et c'est la fin
de la vendange alors on boit un peu
beaucoup même on mange un peu on chante
beaucoup je vous vois avec une GRTE de
raisin quel poid à peu près écoutez
celle-là n'est pas extrêmement lour
monsieur dark on a eu combien de notre
notre record ça a été combien de grappe
une grappe 1 k
200 ça fait à peu près combien de de
ctil de vin oh là mon
dieu ça donne presque 1 L de vin et bien
bravo une grappe de raisin donant un L
de vin à ce propos je crois madame que
le vin sera excellent cette année oui je
vous vois venir je crois que vous avez
un petit peu envie de déguster déjà les
premier jus de raisin et pourquoi pas le
J enchane j'aimerais bien et bien je
vous emmène merci
la
[Rires]
soup madame alors je crois que là vous
avez l'intention de nous faire apprécier
le jus de raisin c'est vraiment le jus
de la frille ça n'est pas encore le vin
ni même la Bernage ça n'est pas fermenté
nous sommes prêts des pressoir prir à
l'horizontal
plus raisin
aprsiserment par la
suiteir le nous sommes vous voulez
goûter jeis pris tout à
l' et maintenant quelle est
votreéciation trs
bne
je vous le
souhaite j'en suis maintenant
certain